le rendez vous annuel n'aura pas lieu
cette année les sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines ne viendront pas toquer aux
portes pour vendre leur femme du
calendrier c'est par souci d'exemplarité
qu'ils ont fait ce choix
on ne pourrait pas effectivement
imaginer que les sapeurs pompiers ne
soit pas exemplaire dans le domaine et
ne donne pas l'exemple à la population
du respect des mesures gouvernementales
liées effectivement aux contraintes
sanitaires
il sera quand même possible de se
procurer le traditionnel calendrier des
flyers explicatifs seront distribués
dans chaque boîte aux lettres yvelinoise
les trois façons de faire sont les
suivantes la première en fait à travers
un qr code qui est imprimé en fait sur
le flyer qui sera distribuée et qui
permet effectivement un virement par
correspondance
la seconde c'est la page facebook de
chaque amical quand elles existent
et puis la troisième c'est simplement
d'adresser un chèque par voie postale à
l'amicale ti siège au centre de secours
de compétent
en fonction de l'adresse à la réception
des dons l'amicale enverra les
calendriers ces dons seront
intégralement reversés aux amicales
qu'il utilise tout au long de l'année
l'amicale de deux sapeurs pompiers en
fait est au centre de secours
l'équivalent du comité des oeuvres
sociales d'une entreprise c'est à dire
que elle a pour mission principalement
en fait une action sociale et solidaire
envers les sapeurs pompiers et leurs
familles elle contribue également en
fait à effectuer des dons au profit de
l'oeuvre des pupilles et orphelins de
sapeurs pompiers c'est dont saft aussi
améliorer les conditions de travail au
sein des casernes
les sapeurs-pompiers appelle aussi à la
vigilance de chacun afin d'éviter des
arnaques